[Music]
this machine is the assisted chin to
change the weight on the machine you
pull the yellow pin out and placing your
selected weight
the next step is to pull the pin out to
move the paddle P into place
to mount the machine you stand on the
steps provided and then from there you
decide which of the three hand positions
you are going to use narrow slightly
wide and wide grip
you then Place one knee onto the pad
along with the other and then begin the
movement ensuring that you keep a good
Tempo in order to contract your muscles
accordingly
when pulling yourself up you don't want
to pull yourself up too far so that the
weight hits the bar on the way up
you want to ensure that on the relaxing
phase you're allowing your muscles to
extend before pulling back up again
to Dismount the machine you move one leg
off of the Putt and then slowly release
the other knee up onto the pad until the
weight makes a stack then step off the
machine using the steps again
foreign